- It tastes green.
Does that make any sense?
(slinky electronic music)
- Mm, I like that one.
- Like got a good texture to it.
- They are a little bit nuttier
and a little bit creamier.
- It's dense, it's fudge-y,
just what you want in a brownie.
- You can definitely tell
they're not as sweet.
- If somebody handed this out at a party,
I would have no clue.
- I don't really taste
avocado, I can just tell
something's up with them.
- Has in aftertaste, of shrimp,
(vinyl record scratching)
there's a shrimp-y aftertaste.
I'm not kidding here.
- All together, they're
delicious either way.
- I think it's because you
mentioned it, I taste this,
taste like fish now.
If you hadn't said anything,
it would just taste
like the color green.
- I could deal with these
if I want to feel healthier.
- I mean, it's a damn brownie,
how could you not love it?
- I say it tastes like it
could possibly have weed in it.
I've never had a weed brownie, but--
- It tastes nothing like
a weed brownie. (laughing)